I like to start by just introducing the
problem that I want to talk about so I'm
going to talk about a computational
problem or statistical problem where we
try to infer some parameters and
specifically Department is that we want
to infer the ancestry of individuals so
the most kind of general problem that
you have a set of genotype to set of
individuals and you want to find each
individual you want to know where they
are on so no the one of them is from
Asia and other one from Europe and so on
and so there's a question that seems in
turn of a sick and fundamental to me
which is how well can we do this given a
specific data set given a specific
method or what's the best matter that we
could use to do this so how accurate can
we be so let's say instead of looking at
the world can we look at Europe and say
from which countries each person is form
and maybe we can go even further and say
from which series each person from an I
don't know each neighborhood okay so so
this is the this is the problem setting
and before I go I dive into the methods
themselves I'd like to say a few words
about why I and many others think that
this is a important problem and it's
been studied quite a bit in the last 15
years so some activation so this picture
probably some of you I've seen it before
in my slides or other people's slides so
this is a data from a statement portion
this is actually an old slide where they
had back then 90 samples and the out
that's the output of the program
structure of Jonathan Pritchard is here
and so what you can see here is that
every so you have 90 samples and each
sample has this rectangle with three
different colors the different colors
correspond to the different ancestries
so in this case we're looking at Porto
Rican population photo Ricans in general
you can say that there's three made
major ancestry is that that came to
Puerto Rico one is Europeans Africans
and
Native Americans so you can see here
that every individual has a different
ancestry so they're all Puerto Ricans
but this guy here is one hundred percent
European and this guy here is
eighty-five percent Native American they
would all identify themselves as Berto
Ricans but genetically they are
different in they have different
ancestries a few years later is steppin
in this group they collected more data
and actually now they have much more
data but this is from two or three years
ago I guess and you see two populations
here at the top population is the
Mexicans the bottom populations the
Puerto Ricans and what you can see so
this the three right populations here
the Europeans Africans and Native
Americans and you can see even between
the Puerto Ricans and the Mexicans
there's differences right there's
differences in in the sense that the
ancestry the African ancestry the Native
American ancestry and the European
ancestry or distributed differently in
the two populations and potentially
let's say well you know we kind of know
the history of these of these places but
if we didn't know the history of these
places we could theoretically know
something about the history of these two
places just by looking at them right so
I mean by looking at this graph so for
instance you know you see that there is
much less much more African population
in Puerto Rico that tells you something
about the migration from Africa to to
Puerto Rico right so it's maybe not very
quantitative this way but it's still you
can you can see easily even from this
picture that you have a lot of
information about what happened in the
past based on what you see in these
pictures so this population specifically
are admixed populations and when you
think about ethnic population you think
about populations that maybe 10 20 30
generations ago at least recently a
mixed population or like in a nick nick
Patterson stock so I'm talking about
with very recent ad mix admixture so
let's say 20 generations ago 500 years
ago
the Africans and Europeans before the
Africans were brought to the Americas
then they basically didn't really meet
so we have two populations that were
separated for a long time and then they
started mixing after the first
generation you have three types of
individuals individuals that both their
parents are red individuals both their
parents are blue and individuals that
have one red chromosome and one blue
chromosome after a few popular after a
few generations due to recombinations
you have these mosaic so every
individual is basically going to be a
mosaic of red and blue populations so
the this is what we have in the genomes
of the individuals and one of the basic
problems here is how to identify these
regions when is an individual red web
ancestry and when is it a blue ancestry
and there's been a lot of methods
including it from our groups from our
group that try to do this and again why
is this useful so one of the basic one
of the most important reasons for this
is that this can be used when you look
when you look for genes that are
associated with disease so imagine so
this technique is called admixture
mapping and the basic idea is that you
have let's say that you map the genomes
of individuals and you know in every
position whether the individual is blue
or red now you're looking for regions
such as this one which are enriched in
the red population or in the blue
population so this would be an
interesting region and and then you'd
say that this region is associated with
the disease so you're taking individuals
that are cases forgot to mention that so
the assumption is so let's say I take
african-americans at our cases and I'm
looking for European ancestry in a
specific region and then I suspect that
they have an enrichment in this European
ancestry because there is a gene over
there that is associated order this
it's associated with with the disease so
admixture mapping has been widely used
across many different phenotypes you
need there's a few things you need to
have in order for this to work
specifically need to have different
prevalence in the between the two the
two you know the Africans and Europeans
if you looking at African African
Americans for instance and you need to
have also a different allele frequency
between the two populations the other
thing which is useful when you look at
this kind of data and that was
demonstrated in two different papers one
of them by Joe November's group and the
other one by David Reich's book that you
could look at this information and see
that and calculate the recombination
rates basically so every point every
break point that goes from blue to red
or red to blue is an evidence for the
fact that you had recombination in the
last 20 generations in this case so you
can just count essentially how many do
you have in every region and that gives
you an estimate of how likely is it to
have a recombination in a specific
region so that's a kind of motivation to
why would one want to do this kind of
thing another very important motivation
which is I assume again in this case
probably everyone told me they had many
eight percent of the audience would know
this so there's a lot there's been a lot
of studies in the last ten years I guess
of genome-wide Association studies where
people have been looking at the entire
genome and they were looking for snips
that are associated with a specific
disease so you take cases and controls
where you take a continuous phenotype
and you're trying to assert to correlate
the field type with a sneak so this map
shows it's actually pretty old it's from
2010 but it what it shows is every point
here corresponds to a snip that was
associated with a specific phenotype the
colors correspond to different
phenotypes and today you already have
thousands of these snakes that are
associated with
now in order to do this the analysis
there you must take into account the
fact that maybe for instance the case
collected cases and controls from
different populations because if you
collect cases and controls from
different populations then you'll see a
lot of false positives a lot of snips
that are going to be I'm going to have
different allele frequencies between the
cases and the controls are going to look
as if they are associated with the
disease but they're just associated with
the fact that this come from different
populations and if you so this picture
is actually from paper by young cattle
in a genetic 2011 and what you see here
is a typical thing of that's a QQ plot
of the expected p value compared to the
observed e value with and without
adjusting for the population structure
and in fact this is a I kind of like
this example because what it shows it
what they showed in this paper is they
looked at so they looked at basically
children they started with with Latino
children that that had leukemia and they
treated them and they wanted to see who
responds to the treatment and who
doesn't so these were the cases new
controls it couldn't find anything when
they did just the June the normal G was
but they did find that if they look at
the Native American ancestry did nigut
children made more than ten percent
Native American ancestry have three
times more chance of basically not
responding to the treatment so this is
kind of the ancestry itself was what was
what what gave the prediction but you
couldn't find any specifics name you
could then also look at the local
specific ancestry and you'd see that you
have some snips that are or regions that
are that have enriched enrichment for
Native American ancestry so that's kind
of the admixture mapping idea okay so so
this was not even the motivation and I
want to talk about a little bit about
what are the current frameworks or
current and previous frameworks for for
answers for inference so
again in the most basic setting what we
have is some type of a clustering
problem you think you can think of a
mixture model where you want to give to
every individual in this case three
numbers that will tell you what's the
fraction of the European African and
Native American ancestry and you can do
it in a supervised setting and you can
do it in an unsupervised setting okay so
all of these frameworks have been
explored and again you can look at the
level of the snip which will be local
specific answers when you can look at
the level of the entire genome which
will give you just the global ancestry
so again there's been dozens of methods
of that are doing this and there's those
differences between them but the the
most basic idea if I take out if I just
kind of try to simplify it is the
following that if you have a set of
population in this case three
populations I and again I'm looking at
this is actually true boat in the
supervised and unsupervised case but
let's just think about the supervised
days i have Europeans i have africans
and i have agents and let's say that i
have these three populations so i
collected samples from these three
populations and then i see that in the
first napus i have an a little frequency
of thirty percent for the Europeans
twenty percent for the Africans twenty
percent for the agents for the second
snippet of ten percent twenty percent in
ten percent and so on so I can measure
for every snake what's the allele
frequency in each population again in
the unsupervised case I have to kind of
learn both things together I have to
learn what which ones are the ancestral
population and which ones are the snips
which ones are the allele frequency so I
have to learn the entire matrix in
supervised case it's a little bit easier
but once I have this then I can use this
now as a model okay so i can think about
it as a generative model and now when i
see an individual and now i get a new
individual i want to know whether this
individual is african european or asian
in this case or maybe a mix but let's
just say that i want to say
is one of the three then I can just
write down the likelihood so if I see
that the person is almost like SI and I
know that they live the probability for
asp and it's just going to be P Square
and again AG it's going to be 2 p 1
minus p and so on and i can just
multiply everything or just take the
look like look like look likely like
this is going to be there look
likelihood of a specific snip so this is
the most simple idea and again it's
still very useful even if you just use
maybe i'll talk for just a second for
just a minute about this idea so when
the first time I started thinking about
this problem I was thinking I was
basically looking at the data and I was
and I ran structure specifically and I
saw the structure can take Africans and
Europeans and just with a few hundred
snips find the structure essentially
clustered them not too many snips now if
you try to think about it theoretically
and again I'm trying to aim this to the
theoretical computer science in the
audience here or maybe the others that
are going to be interested in that if
you try to analyze this and say how come
structure can do this with so many so
few snips it's not clear it's not
completely clear that you can do this
actually the first analysis that you do
is you just say well that I have a
snipping it I have a bunch of sniffing
their independent I can apply a Chernoff
bound and I can see that there is a
concentration around each of the so it
around each of these vectors right so
essentially it's kind of if you know
more than normal constant and of a
normal concentration so cha know Bonnie
would be the equivalent of the normal
concentration and then you then you you
should eventually see that after that an
African is an African European is a
European but if you you know if you put
the math together and try to use this
Chernoff bounds you get it to the math
tells you that you need about ten
thousand snips not a few hundred snips
and so I kind of thought about it
together actually with a group here in
Berkeley with cetera and we try to think
about what why is it the case and what
we found
is that really what you need is not only
the length of the of the number of snail
is important but also the number of
individuals and we came to we came up
with bounds that use the entire matrix
the size of the entire matrix and
essentially the FST between the two
populations in order to tell to you know
to tell you what's the upper bound and
actually lower bounded and they're tight
in this case of what you need to do it
we did get to something which is about I
mean we didn't really care about the
exact constants but it was a few hundred
snips so it's it's not I think it's not
completely intuitive that it should work
as well as it does but it works really
well it's at least if the snip the
populations are far enough from each
other okay now so there's more
sophisticated methods and again
different groups have been working on
this week recently had a method that we
call lamp LD that basically uses both
the linkage disequilibrium we use this
kind of hmm model that takes the two
populations together in Windows I'm not
going to get into this into the details
but the basic idea here is that you look
at all the snips and you think about a
model that that allows you for the kind
of recombination it's not really
recombinations because you're not you're
not modeling exactly the population
genetics here but you give a descriptive
model of a descriptive generative model
for the sequence now so we and again
others there was at least 45 other
methods that are trying to do this have
been doing this in each one each time
there was a paper came out and gave a
little bit better with a accuracy on the
African Americans the accuracy is really
you know as I said before it's with a
few hundred snips you can do it so it's
very easy to do this also on the local
the local specific ancestry is very easy
to do when you go to the Latino
population it's a little bit more
difficult but still
again based on simulations we get to I
can't remember the exact numbers but
it's in the high 90s right 95 96 percent
accuracy but we also wondered about what
what happens in if you try to do
something which is not to evaluate it
without looking at simulations and it's
not clear exactly how to do this but
what we what we did is we took in a
statement Bush's data from you see
yourself he has trios mother father and
child and you can ask the following
question let's say that I give the
mother the father and the child the
three of them to the program lamp LD or
any of the other methods that are there
we tried it on four different methods
actually and and then you just ask
whether they were made our Mendelian
inconsistencies between what you get for
the father for the mother and the child
so I mean dealing consistencies I mean
that if let's say that you have that you
say that the matter is African the
father is European so the mother and
father are African is a childhood
European in a specific position so
that's obviously there is a mistake
summer in one of them okay so and we did
that and what we found is that overall
like you expect we you know the results
of the simulations are a bit too
optimistic but it didn't sound like
they're very optimistic okay it was up
to the kind of a constant but in some
regions in the genome the errors were
much higher so for instance in the HLA
region you know and in the telomeres
there's regions in the in the genome
that are much more difficult to to work
with probably because we all these
methods assume that there is a
neutrality all these mid methods assume
that the recommendation rates are kind
of known or they try to estimate them
again based on the travel t so in
regions such as the HLA this is not
probably not so easy to do because there
is probably selection and probably maybe
the recombination rates are not well
estimated over them so this is kind of a
steeler it's a kind of a black hole in
that we don't really know the answer for
this specific reasons but for the most
of the genome we get reasonable results
again when we look at Latinos so if you
go for 245 a mixture for five
populations it's probably a harder
problem we don't really know how these
methods work okay so the next or another
type of ancestry in front city could do
is you can think maybe I don't want to
cluster them because this is kind of
arbitrary maybe I want to think about
the whole thing is a continuum okay so
this is a famous picture from Carlos's
cuz speculum 2008 together with Joe
November and what you see here is the
purpose data which is laid of European
people with European ancestry and this
is just a PC a map pc one and pc to the
colors correspond to the country of
origin right so you have this this is
the map of Europe you can see the cut
the country of origin and if it's the
first time you see then you probably
kind of needs it's really surprising if
you if you've seen it 20 times and maybe
it's you know it seems like very normal
but its first time you see it it's it's
it's really surprising and smear it so
it's it's surprising why because you
know you don't really it's not
completely clear you're doing PCA right
it's kind of magic why would why should
it work why should the first two pieces
correspond to geography maybe they
should correspond to something else
right maybe pc3 should correspond to
geography it's not completely clear that
it should work but if your we ran the
corrections pc to correspond to day and
examples are wrong yeah exactly so yeah
you need so if you don't do any QC here
then you know you're not gonna get you
you're not going to so it's it's it's
not yeah so so that's a good point
across okay so so the thing is there is
still a disadvantage when you use PCA
because PCA doesn't it basically seems
linearity and that means that you
actually you don't have this generate
you know probability statement probably
stick generative model that they showed
you before with models like structure or
lamp and things like that so and you can
say well you know what do I care my why
do I need this this generative model but
the thing is if you want to think about
individuals are diploid and not a plate
then you do want to use this this kind
of model because if a person is a mix of
as Swedish and Italian for instance then
pc i would give you a point in the
middle right and it's it's just because
they just take the average of the two
essentially okay so but if you have a
model a probabilistic model that is
explicit you could potentially tell
apart the two parents okay I'm not
saying that it's easy and it's you know
from our experiment it's not so easy to
get at least not that accuracy but but
you can get well in reasonable accuracy
I'll show you a bit later okay so
together with Ellis a reskin here and
with Joe November we thought about you
know we basically wearing UCLA and we
thought you know how how should we do
that we started thinking about explicit
models for this is model for continuous
continuum spatial answers to basic so
the basic the most the simplest idea
that you could use which is essentially
what to use eventually is is the
following so you have let's say that you
have Spanish Germans and Russians and
you have 20 snip of the twenty percent
of minor allele frequency in Spain fifty
percent in Germany and eighty percent in
Russia then if you have now a French
person then you expect the French person
to be somewhere between Spain and
Germany for you know for most mix maybe
not all of them but for many many of the
snips and so we expect the allele
frequency in France to be something like
thirty five percent
so what we did is we said okay so let's
think about the following model let's
have a model that says that given that
you're from point XY on the map I'll
have an allele frequency which is a
function of x and y it's a continuous
function of x and y okay and this
continuous function has to have a few
properties so one of the properties is
that it has its probability it has to be
a number between zero and one and the
other one at least were the first thing
we wanted to try was to say that we want
to have some kind of linearity okay so
it's not exactly we can't have it
exactly near function because it's done
it's not going to be between zero and
one but then it's easy to do because you
can just take Sigma right so this
function is essentially a linear
function which is bounded between zero
and one so so you put really this is
kind of a map of a specific snip and in
this in this map you see that I don't
know if you go to let's eat turkey
you'll have a ten percent minor little
frequency for that snape if you go to
England you have something like seventy
percent and so on okay so so the entire
map of Europe is you have for every
specific point here you having a little
frequency that it is determined by this
function we call this function slope
functions so so then the question is how
do you fit now you have a probabilistic
model now you have to fit the model
basically to fit the parameters so we
just write the likelihood the problem is
that that if you want to maximize the
likelihood this is not a convex problem
and it's not very easy to optimize but
luckily we observe that if you fix the
positions so these are the positions of
the individuals then i can try now to
estimate these maps for each of the
snips so this is the likelihood function
and so the sum is over all the
individuals and then sum of all the
snips of the likelihood function that i
showed you before where the f are simply
these slope functions
okay so what you can see here is that if
I fix the individuals then the problem
of Maximus de likely just breaks down so
that every snip can be maximized
separately so every snip now has a just
summation over all the individuals and
it's only really two parameters three
parameters because we have this B and a
is a vector of size 2 so it's like three
parameters that we have to estimate for
every snake from the entire genome it's
very very easy and relatively fast to do
this step okay so this is if you have
the positions of the individuals the
thing is if you have the maps you can
easily find the positions in exactly the
same way essentially so you basically
now fix these maps so the A's and the
bees are fixed and the functions now are
just functions of X and again it's a
convex function okay and you can
separate it for every individual you
have a maximization problem for that
individual right you don't have to
maximize it for all the individuals
together and so what the actual data
there's very few mutations that like
started in Central Europe and or just
peaked there in the middle okay so when
we the answer is yes because I don't
know if very few but the majority of the
of them are not like that the one we
started working on the data we didn't
know okay and we just said actually we
said we'll just try that and it's
probably not gonna work and then we'll
try to think about something smarter but
that worked so okay so okay so there's a
chicken-and-egg problem here we don't
really know if we want to do the
unsupervised case at least we don't
really know the positions we don't
really know the maps but we can just
iterate we start with random set of
positions and then we find the best maps
and then we find once with the maps are
known we find the best positions and so
on so we try that on the papas data i'll
just say again what it is that's the
same data that John and Carlos
use for the PC a map that I showed you
before so there's a 30 and 85
individuals here and that was that we
had 500,000 snips and each individual
out of these thirteen fourteen hundred
individuals has four grandparents it
came from the same country okay so
remember it's the same country it
doesn't mean you know Spain is big
friends is big Germany is big it doesn't
it's not the best data it would have
been better to get the same city but
like that's that's what we have right
now okay so what you see here is the
starting point we just put them in like
in a random instead of random positions
and I'm going to show you a quick movie
and show you how how it converges so
it's going to repeat three times but you
see the first time so it basically
basically converges to to the map and
you know if you look at it carefully you
consider there's a bit of differences
between what you get here and what you
get with the PCA but you know
qualitative leads it's it's very similar
the in terms of we call the method spa
the median error is somewhat lower about
ten percent lower than PCA so we get 250
kilometers instead of 20 and 80
kilometers so the distance is to the you
know each again the it to each we don't
know what we're in the country do they
come from so we go we go to the biggest
city yes
populations are expanding we don't but
in principle I think this this is a very
interesting problem we looked at a look
at the snips that have the largest
slopes and these were you know Elsie
thla and so on so these are regions that
have not to be many of them were not to
be under selection and you know we found
a few others that we you know are not
necessarily not to be under selection so
it could could be that there are no
surgeon we don't really have a proof of
it because there's no neutral model here
so it's very difficult to prove it but
in principle I think you know that's
kind of one of the in my last slide I
have this bullet that says I think it's
kind of a very interesting open question
to see what can you learn from these
slow functions or maybe other slope
functions about the mog raphy about
population genetics parameters yes no
yeah that's again a great question and
that's that's something you can easily
add you can basically add to this this
is a likelihood model you can add a
problem and the prior could be based on
what you know that is going on in the
map you can say here there's mountains
and here this water so you know you
could you could easily do this and you
cannot even using the you know you can
put the prior so that you know that it
if you look at the map in the bigger
city you should have more people in the
smaller towns there's less people you
have some information that we don't
really use so this is completely you
know tabula rasa I mean like we don't
have we don't know anything we don't use
anything yes
why doesn't it matter oh that's okay so
this is after I moved it sort of young
like that ok so these kilometer is
actually if you just do PCA or you just
do spot without correcting there's no
without correcting for this you know
rotating it and then an action rotating
is not enough you you basically rotate
it and then you regress it ok so it fits
you need to do some kind of a linear
transformation because especially you
can see it easily you can easily see it
from far because there is no I can
always multiply everything by two right
you know so all right it's still going
to be the same the optimal solution by
itself ok so the next step is really to
try to account for linkage
disequilibrium this work is with your
elbow on my student and with dumb person
you from UCLA and so you want to come
for LD LD again for the theory people in
the audience it's basically just assume
that there's correlations between snips
and usually this correlation is only
between steps that are very close to
each other in the genome so so the first
question is why do we even care about LD
and and here is at least one reason so
if you look at the at this panel we
basically assume that the snips are
independent now it may not be too bad
but maybe it is bad it's not really
clear right this is the result that we
have a spot for a Spanish population
from so this population is from spain
and the colors correspond to the
different regions in spain deter from so
it could be so this color these guys are
from galicia and these guys are a
believer from the best country i can't
remember now
and these guys are from all over Spain
as you can see so it's kind of a mix it
doesn't really work very well when we
look at a dispatch bang okay if we run
PCA then we get this result here so
again you have some structure it's not
that you don't have any structure but
you can't really make any inference now
about the migration patterns in Spain
based on that right i mean you wouldn't
want to do something like that here so
it's not you know it's we always see the
map of europe and then we sell pcie
works great yeah it works great and
again after the QC that colors did right
but but then even after QC just get this
kind of phenomenon what you can see it
may be hard to see but there's like the
second pc is actually not really
geography the second pc what it
corresponds to is an inversion in
chromosome 8 okay so this is if i only
look at the chromosome 8 region of the
inversion this is what I guess what I
get the same thing as the second pc so
it's done it's a very long in version of
a few mega bases and there's very high
LD over there because of the inversion
so so there's a problem over there and
this problem was known also before you
know it's not that we found we find it
specifically with this data but people
looked at LD and PCs and specifically
and actually also ldm local specific
ancestry and so that it can cause
problems okay so sorry this is
okay so what we do is we try to do too
what we try to do is we try to say okay
so let's now think about slope functions
the take into account LD ok so the same
framework is spa but now let's get
better better slope functions over if in
slope function but this one this time so
functions also take into account the LD
so what we do is we do again something
relatively simple what we do is we say
let's split the genome into
non-overlapping windows and in each
window we have a string g IJ it's that
individual I window J so again this is a
string it's not just one snip now it's
set of snips and we are going to assume
that in this region we have a
multivariant note that basically the
gene G comes from a multivariate normal
distribution with variance covariance
matrix that is fixed across europe in
this case or cross pein across the
region but the mean depends on the
position of the individual ok so again
this you can think of it as again a
linear function but this time I'm taking
into account the correlations so again I
can just write down the likelihood and
the likelihood of the of the genotypes
given basically this is for one window
for better J and Sigma J so this is just
a multivariate normal likely what's nice
about it so one of the things that
happened with Spy is that it turned out
I mean I showed you this picture but it
actually takes a long time to run and
one of the nice features of this this
formulation is that we have a closed
form optimization given over just two
minutes giving each one of the of the
parameters so if i fix Sigma then I can
easily get X and better if I sick
a fixed better than again it can get the
other ones and so on so I'm going to
skip how we do this this is just
formulas that you get by solving this so
again given the positions i can just get
better in sigma and given sigma i can
basically get x given Sigmund better
kinetics so let me show you some results
so one thing that we see is that if we
take spa sorry this is BC a spa and we
call it local localization correction
for LD so we take the three of them you
see that if you increase the number of
snippety using this is the art r square
threshold so if I just prune the data
with point2 let's say you use blink or
any other basically just take every two
snips if they have an R square of modern
point to them to throw away one of them
and this is the same thing 4.5 and so on
we get to a situation where we here we
get worse and worse results and here we
actually get better the results when we
increase the number of steps we compared
the method to pca but on all the snakes
the pca on data that is pruned with
point to actually to smart pc air which
is a method by nick pattinson and alkis
price David Wright that basically uses
also tries to look at LD for PCA and spa
inspired pruned and you can see that the
results are improve compared to Speights
now it's two of two hundred eleven
kilometers so let me because I'm running
out of time I'm going to skip a few of
the of these slides I want to get to so
a few specific points and then summarize
okay so one thing that we just realized
recently is that there's this you know
so we have these two methods we have spa
we have local and we have pca3 messages
and it seems that there is a lot of
things in common to these methods we
star
thinking about for instance we we look
at what happens when you have rare
variants and they all kind of be the
same they don't work don't try it with
reverence and you know so and then we
looked at some asymptotic things that
would happen and they all seem to be
very to behave similarly and and then
what you know I started to think about
what what's the relation between them
and so you can write down what is the
optimization function for local and just
too because I'm running out of time and
just tell you kind of the what we find
so we find that if we look at window
size one you can think of windows of
local with window size 10 K and sigma
equals the identity so I force Sigma the
standard deviation to be one in this
case we can prove and the proof was here
but I didn't get to it that that we get
the PCA is the solution okay so specie a
can be thought of as a specific is a
special case of local okay now and then
in fact what we can say say that if
Sigma is not necessarily the identity
then quisiera but it's fixed then the
solution of Sigma to the minus half
times the genotype data gives you that
PCA gives you the optimal solution of
local okay and that this kind of thought
get up thatís to an unsupervised
algorithm four loko with l equals one
you simply run PCA and then you find the
Sigma then you optimize the Sigma and
you iterate and you get to something
like that you get the Sigma in the
optimal solution you get the Sigma J
that you have is the variance you kind
of you can you can think about it in the
following wagon when you use PCA
sometimes what you do is you you
actually want to do this you want to
standardize your each of your features
right so you just normalize it to the
features that's what you do in
PCSO just divided by the standard
deviation what we do here is we
calculate the standard deviation but the
standard deviation is based on the mean
a little frequents mean frequency of the
mineral in frequency of that snake based
on the geography of that individual that
we learn during this iterative process
and this can sometimes be useful
actually in every attempt that I didn't
turn in terms of simulation so far it
always gave better results sometimes you
can't really see it by eye but if you
measure important quantitatively what's
the you know you'd start with two
populations you see that you get a
better separation of the two population
when you use this kind of method so this
is even without looking at LD again this
is just looking at using this Sigma and
this example here is just PCA when you
have 10,000 snips out of them 20 snips
with my know a little quick so all the
steps are the same for the two
populations ok I'm done all these things
are the same for the two for the two
populations all those nips are the same
for all of them 20 snips have a minor
allele frequency of point 85 in my
population and point 15 and the other
one this is what you get with PCA and
this is what you get with loko with this
kind of method so it in some cases it
can be so you can see it again there's
some relation between PC and spa I'm not
going to get into it but essentially you
can show that PCA actually has the same
slope functions in spa but it uses some
kind of regularization when it that's
essentially what it does ok so just a
summary I wanted to kind of put out some
open questions that I think are
interesting and again because I'm out of
time I'm not going to say too much about
about them but the first one is what are
really the correct I'm putting it in
parentheses because it's not really
there are correct slow functions ok so
can we come up with better slow
functions that are based on population
genetics parameter basically that
explain the migration and I don't know
the FST the selection and so on and so
and then I'll jump to the last one which
was related to the question that
someone asked you it would be really
interesting I think to try to understand
what's the relation between what we see
here the picture that we see from local
or from other slope functions and
population genetics from this so for
instance if you know gimmick Vince paper
about the relation between PCA and FST
something along these lines I think
would be very interesting because I
think there's there's information of it
we could exploit by looking at different
slope function may be different slope
functions will tell us different things
about the population genetics okay so
with that I'm just going to thank so the
first deezer to work the tech work that
I talked about the first one with when
in young Joe November and elves are
risking and the second one with the
Elven from my lab book done Pacific from
UCLA and in escondido mention Colorado
from USC University of Santiago de
Compostela thank
so you run a spy unsupervised load right
and the examples you gave where you just
don't know it position if anyone and
then at the end you rotate and scale
yeah so presumably you can run it in
supervised more easily if you if you go
located at so I'm sorry so that maybe I
wasn't clear that so with what I showed
you was the unsupervised but the let's
hit the table that I shown these are for
the supervised peace this one's you know
the compares is is that these are the
[ __ ] surprise so we can do both but
appreciate here is running supervisor no
it's fine supervisor because wouldn't
you so you run pc eye on everything okay
but then this transformation that you do
is super fun right okay but inspire you
quick i read it in a supervised way you
could fix a few individual it will also
rescale it wouldn't be just a linear
transformation but you would also be
able to scale the distances between
countries say so but you can do the same
thing with this is being done basically
when you do the you know in principle
you right that's not what we do in spam
button in principally right that you
could make it start to kind of squeeze
the map that's not what to try to do
over there so that's not right buddy in
pca you also use this dysfunction so you
can have the the it's the same function
that they used in again in carlos and
John's day and original paper while you
try to do the rotation and the
regression so this is the part where you
use the supervised part right so
inspired on't go and like try to do
something which is not linger in this
case
so the kids and here